Now, you can't do much about needing the screen on
all the time, but you can control your applications' network
usage pattern. It's important to understand that, in terms of
power consumption, the pattern of network usage, is at least
as important as the total amount of data transferred. There're
definite anti patterns to network usage. It turns out that
the cellular radio is designed to switch to a low
power idle mode, when not in use to conserve battery life.
Let's take a look at the different states the radio
can be in. The cellular radio, has something called the
radio resource controller, or RRC. I'ts kind of like a
traffic controller for the radio. We start out in the idle
state, and, when we make an initial request, it takes
around 100 milliseconds (no period) for us to get connected, and
into the active state. Once we're there of course, we
can make as many requests as we want, and stay active.
Once we're in the active state, though, if we don't
make a request for about a tenth of a second,
we drop into a short sleep mode, which uses less
power, but, it'll take us up to 50 milliseconds in
order to get back into active if we make a
request. Then, if we don't make any requests for another
100 milliseconds, we drop into a long sleep mode. Again,
we can get back to active in under 50 milliseconds.
But, if we don't make any requests for about
ten seconds, we drop all the way back down to
idle. Which will of course take us longer to get
back into active from. The critical part about this of
course, is that each one of these states, has a
different power consumption for a file. Idle of course takes
the least power. Active takes the most. Short sleep and
long sleep, both take inbetween. But, certainly more than idle.
So, it's important for us to leave
the connection idle, as often as possible, and
try not to spend too much time, cycling back and forth between sleep and active.